it's not often that territories are
kicked out of countries most nations
will often go to great lengths to make
sure that they keep hold of as much land
and as many people as humanly possible
yet in 1965 this very thing happened to
Singapore when it was ejected from
Malaysia given how rare willingly losing
a bit of land is throughout human
history the obvious question is why why
was Singapore such a geographically
important region kicked out of Malaysia
so after the Second World War Southeast
Asia was in a place of flux and many of
the areas imperial powers were
struggling to reassert their authority
there this was because throughout the
war these areas had been occupied by
Japan and the Japanese had made sure to
place them under the control of the
native people and at the end of the war
the Europeans returned and had wanted
everything to go back to normal but from
fact know one example is Britain as of
1948 Britain Southeast Asian colonies
were the Federation of Malaya Singapore
Sarawak Brunei and North Borneo
despite Britain's best efforts though by
September 1963 all of these colonies
barring Brunei were independent and all
of these independent states opted to
join the brand-new Malaysia in the same
year for some it was fear of communist
takeover that pushed them into Union and
for Singapore it was about giving it
access to larger markets to increase its
wealth and also Malaysia wasn't Britain
which seemed like a step in the right
direction for Singapore yet a mere two
years after joining Malaysia Singapore
was out but why well the reason was
primarily political Malaysian politics
at this time was dominated by the
Malaysian solidarity convention a
coalition of right-wing parties led by
Tunku Abdul Rahman that represented
Malaysia's largest ethnic groups whereas
Singaporean politics was monopolized but
the People's Action Party which was a
more centrist multi-ethnic party headed
by Lee Kuan Yew now both sides had
rushed into this union because fear of
communism and both immediately ran to
major issues the first was that Malaysia
operated on a system called Malaysian
Malaysia which discriminated against
those who weren't ethnically Malaysian
the second was that the central
government based in Kuala lumper was
sure to clamp down on any idea of
Singapore maintaining any real autonomy
because it was afraid that Singapore
would become the nation's heart as such
the PAP despite promising not to opted
to run in the 1964 federal election
against the MSC now the PAP was crushed
but the fact that it ran on a platform
of ending racial discrimination worried
the MSC the reason being that about 30
to 35 percent of Malaysia's
population was ethnically Chinese and
this voting bloc could have kept the MSE
out of power in fact the only reason why
most Chinese Malaysians voted for the
MSC was the threat that any attempt to
rewrite the system in place would lead
to the government joining Indonesia to
keep the Chinese out of power forever as
such ramen came up with a brilliant idea
let's just kick Singapore out tensions
continue to rise and culminated in a
series of race riots in Singapore whose
population was overwhelmingly Chinese
you should know though that this wasn't
some quick unilateral decision and there
were many months of discussions between
both sides most Singaporean leaders wish
to remain a part of Malaysia but some
like go Kang's we wanted to have much
looser agreement the Malaysian
government said no and so Swee pushed
for Singapore to leave Malaysia all
together the deadlock continued in
tensions rose further and so ramen went
to the Malaysian Parliament and pushed
for a vote on simply expelling Singapore
which he won unanimously on August the
9th 1965 the Singaporean representatives
reluctantly declared independence and
thereafter Singapore would be an
independent nation one which then became
incredibly wealthy so it sort of worked
out in the end I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching but
thanks to my patreon supporters whom you
can see on screen now and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette Ike
Danny Maloney calling Castleman Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white
Jordan long way Chris wicker Gustav
Swann Gareth Turner
Marcus arse nur Maggie pax Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Mo